I feel not in my body.
But I am very present,
if it's possible to be both
not in your body and present
at the same time.
She feels really magical,
which quite
frankly is appropriate because
just having a moment like this,
being here at the Oscars,
that is magical. This
just elevates that magic
to even higher heights,
feels like anything is possible.
And you know what?
I actually believe that.
If you can become an
Academy Award winner
as an openly queer
Afro-Latina,
Anything is possible.
If I was talking to my
younger self, I think
I would just remind her
that your dreams are not too big
and you are not crazy.
I don't know. I enjoy proving
people wrong.
So not that that's what
this moment is.
This is a moment saying
that your hard work,
your dedication and
determination, it does pay off.
So you just have to keep going.